I kind of want to be the knight in
shining armor I know you do you really
love that you want to pluck someone from
show up on your Pony
[Laughter]
that's all fantasy right some girl from
like a Podunk Town who knows nothing
about that's not what it is you've told
us on this podcast as a joke
I don't want like a you know a girl
who's like what's Sushi
no that's ridiculous he's like well let
me tell you yeah no no no no but I I do
want to you know
because nothing nothing he ever said or
did kind of like fully impressed me and
I think he wants to fully impress
somebody because I'm from La like I've
you know I couldn't impress her with
anybody that's a tough thing to say
though if I was with a woman who's like
nothing you said impressed me that would
hurt well like for example he'd be like
I want to take you to this really good
restaurant and I was you know he wants a
girl to be like is it Applebee's and he
so he wants that kind what's like a good
restaurant that you take her to
oh um I would change them to uh probably
like boa or something no boo yeah yeah
you're not impressed by that I grew up
here okay no and she's also she's a
fancy girl no but I grew up here in L.A
yeah even when I wrote I remember when
she saw me perform like when we're that
I was impressed by yeah but it wasn't
like was it impressive yeah because it
was the you followed Chris Rock it was
an Oscar's weekend and I I thought you
were you you absolutely crushed that
night oh and I was like holy [__] Bobby
Lee's like but I love Bobby Bobby's at
but it's no no boo I mean
yeah I did date a girl though uh went on
one date with this girl she went to the
Improv to see me perform yeah and
afterwards ago what'd you think she goes
I don't find you funny what she said
that that's like almost a gift though
you're like [__] you I don't yeah yeah
yeah but it's like did you date a girl
who didn't think no right yeah yeah
that's my job I mean I mean if you don't
if you don't love them nah that'd be
tough if you didn't like
because I'm on I'd want to bring you on
the road occasionally if I'm never home
and then I look to the left of the stage
and you're just like yeah exactly that
is something that okay I'm wrong you
always impress me when I when you're on
the road and we went together there was
never a time that I didn't I wasn't like
in awe of you yeah but also if I didn't
do bad you never did like no but with
this girl if I ate it I'd be like we
just got a different show whatever but I
thought I did okay yeah and still she
was like nah do you think she was just
trying to I like Nathan for you she says
he sounds like a [__] idiot I mean
it's like saying like it's like going to
see a comedy move and you're like I like
the favorite and you're like that's a
different genre a sad type of movie yeah
uh no that's uh and you followed Rock
and you did well I mean that's I love
following someone like rock because it's
like the crowd's in such a good mood
they just saw Chris Rock everyone thinks
that's a hard spot but it's like the
best spot it is the best spot yeah I
mean I used to do it after I mean
Rogan's a little hard sometimes is he a
little bit you know what I mean but um
it feels good to survive after like a
thunderous performance yeah doesn't it
feel good like like I got it I didn't
look like a fool yeah rock is I just
thought I was the Knicks game last week
and I saw Rock and he's so he just walks
up to you and he goes comedian yeah yeah
like is Chris Rock Mark Normand what the
[__] happened yeah yeah but Will Smith
really suing him no no I saw a yes no
pull it up is he really or what
I'm not I didn't make this up oh his
face hit his palm
I mean rocks joke jokes on Will Smith
were [__] great hilarious so good
maybe that's why he's sewing